* Arie aus "Carmen":
"Habanera" von Georges Bizet *
Mehrmals am Tag spielt sich etwas
Merkwürdiges im Herzen von Genf ab.
Nicht so schlimm.
Stellen Sie sich auf die Waage!
Dutzende von Menschen, v.a. Frauen,
warten auf das Wiegen
und das anschliessende Urteil.
Wunderbar!
Sie haben 900 g verloren. Schön!
Wir sind bei Weight Watchers,
dem führenden
globalen Schlankheitsinstitut
mit 1,5 Mrd. Fr. Umsatz
und über 1 Mio. Kunden weltweit,
davon 10'000 in der Schweiz.
Hier ist eine Topfigur
Massstab aller Dinge.
Doch ist dieses Versprechen seriös
oder nur eine Art Wunderrezept?
Für unsere Recherchen begleiten wir
eine Gruppe von Kandidaten
beim Abnehmen, mit der Bewilligung
von oberster Stelle.
Karine gilt als der beste
weibliche Coach der Schweiz.
Wenn ihr genug Ausdauer habt,
werdet ihr euer Idealgewicht
sicher erreichen.
Ein ganzes Jahr lang
folgen wir den Kandidaten.
Werden Sie es schaffen, abzunehmen
und ihre Traumfigur zu erlangen?
* Fulminante Schlussklänge
der "Habanera" *
In der Gruppe von Karine
treffen wir drei Teilnehmer,
die Gewicht verlieren wollen.
Marjorie hat bereits 16 kg weniger
und will noch weitere 15 abnehmen.
Ich hatte nie Probleme,
mich hübsch zu machen.
Doch als die Waage mir zeigte,
dass mein Gewicht stieg und stieg,
bis zu dreistelligen Zahlen,
da wusste ich,
dass ich etwas tun musste.
Wie viel war es denn?
- 102 kg.
Denis wird bald in Rente gehen.
Er hat gemerkt,
dass seine Figur nicht mehr so ist
wie in seiner Jugend.
Sein Ziel: 20 kg abnehmen.
Wir haben letztes Jahr
am Strand ein Video gedreht.
Ich gefiel mir überhaupt nicht.
Da sagte ich mir: So nicht.
Ich habe keine Lust,
dick und unattraktiv zu werden.
Ich möchte doch etwas Stil haben.
Und dann Emilie.
Sie hat genug von ihren Pfunden
und will unbedingt abnehmen.
Doch das ist nicht das erste Mal.
Vor ein paar Jahren
hat die junge Krankenschwester
mit Weight Watchers 15 kg verloren.
Doch dann wurde sie schwanger
und nahm wieder zu,
sogar ein paar Kilo mehr als vorher.
Dennoch hat sie ihr Vertrauen
in die Methode nicht verloren.
Kann ich behilflich sein?
Ja, ich möchte mich wieder
bei Weight Watchers anmelden.
Es sind immer noch meine Kilos.
Da sind Sie bei uns richtig.
Wir werden Ihnen helfen und Sie
motivieren, Ihr Ziel zu erreichen.
Mein Sohn ist schon grösser.
Jetzt möchte ich etwas für mich tun.
Ich möchte,
dass er stolz auf mich ist.
Er merkt, wenn ich mich
nicht gut fühle in meiner Haut.
Ich weiss nicht, wie es herauskommt,
aber vielleicht
schäme ich mich dann nicht mehr.
Er wird spüren, dass seine Mama
selbstbewusster wirkt.
Das ist besser für die Familie.
Haben Sie ein Idealgewicht,
bei dem Sie sich gut fühlen?
Ich möchte vorerst
gute 10 kg abnehmen.
Dann tun wir das
Schritt für Schritt.
Ein erstes Etappenziel wäre 10 kg.
Es gibt einen Punkt,
wenn Sie es erreichen.
Ich weiss,
dass es nicht einfach ist.
Man muss sich
auf kleine Ziele konzentrieren,
damit man nicht zu enttäuscht ist
und die Motivation nicht verliert.
Ich beginne mit 10 kg und dann
legen wir ein weiteres Ziel fest.
Wir werden ja sehen.
Für Emilie findet jede Woche
dasselbe Ritual statt:
erst die Waage, dann das Treffen
mit den andern Teilnehmern.
Der Preis: 90 Fr. im Monat.
Zudem bietet Weight Watchers
leichte Fertigmalzeiten
und Kochbücher zum Verkauf an.
4'000?
10'000. Juste pour etre en forme.
Ich hoffe, ihr habt gute Erfolge
auf der Waage erzielt.
Das Prinzip ist dasselbe
wie bei den anonymen Alkoholikern.
Hier darf man
im vertrauten Kreis reden.
Karine, heute Coach,
war selbst auch einmal Kundin.
Wo stehen Sie beim Abnehmen?
- Ich stagniere.
Der Winter ist bald vorbei,
der Frühling kommt.
Eine schwierige Zeit.
Was machen wir,  Marjorie?
Man kommt wieder zum Treffen.
- Sehr gut.
Und man versucht,
sich zu motivieren,
etwas in der Ernährung zu verändern,
zu diversifizieren.
Haben Sie etwas ausprobiert,
was Christiane helfen könnte?
Ich habe dieselben Probleme,
auch ich brauche Hilfe.
Vielleicht hat jemand anders
gute Tipps?
Wo stehen Sie, Marjorie?
- Ich habe 16 kg verloren.
Aber seit Langem
stagniert mein Gewicht.
Ich bin eigentlich sehr zufrieden,
denn der Weg dahin war lang.
Und jetzt ist es schwierig,
die Motivation zu finden.
Sie müssen die Motivation
wiederfinden, die Sie hatten,
als Sie das erste Mal
zu Weight Watchers kamen.
Ich ermutige Sie,
sich ein kleines Ziel zu setzen
und sich nicht aufzugeben.
Ich betone noch einmal, wenn alle es
schaffen, 500 g zu verlieren,
bin ich als Coach überglücklich.
Und somit sage ich euch:
Das war sehr sehr gut!
Donnerstagmittag haben wir 18,9 kg
Gewichtsverlust erreicht,
das sind durchschnittlich 850 g.
Bravo, das ist Spitze!
(Denis) Das war nicht ich.
Nicht dank Denis - macht nichts!
Jene, die zu diesem phantastischen
Gewichtsverlust beigetragen haben,
wissen es.
Sie werden sich freuen, im Frühling
ein neues Badekleid zu kaufen.
Nächste Woche reden wir über gute
und leichte Speisen auf dem Teller.
Ich wünsche euch
eine wunderbare Woche.
Diese Frau, Jean Nidetch,
hat das Konzept von Weight Watchers
in den 60er-Jahren entwickelt.
Sie war 107 kg schwer.
Nach mehreren erfolglosen Diäten
lud sie Freundinnen ein,
um mit ihnen abzunehmen,
und sie schaffte es.
Aufgrund dieser Erfahrung
gründete sie die Weight Watchers.
Der Erfolg war fulminant.
Das Unternehmen
eroberte die USA im Sturm
und entwickelte sich
zu einem weltweiten Imperium.
Die amerikanische Marke schien
das Wunderrezept gefunden zu haben.
Die Zutaten: Zusammenkünfte
mit einem Coach und ein Punktesystem,
welches das Kalorienzählen
erleichtert.
Also nur Regeln einhalten
und garantiert abnehmen.
Weight Watchers
gibt sich als Methode,
bei der man essen darf
und das Gewicht kontrollieren kann.
Also keine Diät.
In Paris treffen wir
den Psychiater Jean-Philippe Zermati.
Er ist Spezialist für Fettleibigkeit
und führt ein Netzwerk
von 400 französischen Ärzten
und Ernährungsberatern,
die Diäten ablehnen.
Er sagt,
ein zu schneller Gewichtsverlust
könne zu Organschäden führen
und sei sinnlos.
Man muss definieren, was eine Diät
überhaupt ist. Nur zu sagen:
"Das ist eine Diät und das nicht",
das geht nicht.
Der gemeinsame Nenner aller Methoden
ist die Kontrolle.
Wenn versucht wird, die Ernährung
bewusst zu kontrollieren,
handelt es sich um eine Diät.
Weight Watchers mit seinem Punkte-
system ist ganz klar eine Kontrolle,
also eine Diät.
Was wir heute wissen:
Nach einem Jahr Diät haben etwa 85 %
der Personen Gewicht verloren,
und nach drei Jahren Diät haben 95 %
wieder ihr Ausgangsgewicht.
Diäten funktionieren also nicht,
aus psychologischen
und physiologischen Gründen.
Dies sagt die Genfer Psychologin
Magali Volery.
Seit Jahren arbeitet sie
mit übergewichtigen Personen.
Bei jeder Beratung beginnt sie
mit einer grundlegenden Aufklärung.
Ah, donc, a midi. Mais en vous
levant a midi, vous ne mangez rien.
Wenn man zunimmt,
geschieht das auf zwei Arten:
Entweder vermehren sich
die Fettzellen, d.h.,
wenn ich drei habe,
werden sechs daraus,
oder die Fettzellen werden grösser.
Man weiss nicht,
welcher Prozess bei der einen
oder der anderen Person stattfindet.
Das Problem ist:
Nur die Vergrösserung der Fettzellen
lässt sich rückgängig machen.
Wenn sich die Fettzellen
vermehrt haben,
kann ihre Zahl nicht mehr
verringert werden. Das bedeutet:
Man kann nie mehr
zum Mindestgewicht zurückkehren.
Man kann zwar 10 % des Gewichts
verlieren und so bleiben.
Mehr abnehmen
ist wahrscheinlich unmöglich.
Über 10 kg abnehmen
und das Gewicht längere Zeit halten
wäre also für die meisten 100 kg
schweren Menschen unmöglich.
Dennoch brüstet sich die weltweit
führende Schlankheitsorganisation
mit spektakulären Gewichtsreduktionen
ihrer Kunden.
Man nennt diese
Gold-Karten-Mitglieder.
Heute hat Laetitia
ein wichtiges Etappenziel erreicht.
Wie fühlen Sie sich?
- Gut.
Erzählen Sie!
Ich habe meine Stabilisierung
nach acht Monaten
mit Weight Watchers beendet.
Wie viel sind Sie losgeworden?
- 26 kg.
Das Gold-Karten-Mitglied Laetitia
darf jetzt gratis
an den Kursen teilnehmen,
wenn sie nicht wieder zunimmt.
Fotos von vorher und nachher.
Ich habe sie auf Facebook gepostet
und habe
sehr viele Antworten bekommen.
Dürfen wir sie sehen?
- Ich muss sie erst finden.
Oh, nicht schlecht!
- Drei Kleidergrössen, mindestens.
Sie dürfen die Anmeldung
für eine Kandidatur
als zukünftige
Weight-Watchers-Muse ausfüllen.
Jedes Jahr gibt es eine Wahl.
Es wäre super,
wenn Sie gewinnen würden.
Spektakuläre Erfolge
wie der von Laetitia
dienen der Marke als Werbung.
Sie werden zu temporären
Aushängeschildern:
"Jeder kann es schaffen."
Coach Karine weiss aber,
dass diese Verheissung Grenzen hat.
Ich denke nicht,
dass das die Mehrheit betrifft.
Es sind Ausnahmen.
Vielleicht Leute, die ihre Ernährung
ins Gleichgewicht bringen mussten
und zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt
ein paar Tipps brauchten,
um den Wert der Nahrungsmittel
zu erkennen.
Sie kamen zu Weight Watchers
und verstanden die Tipps.
Für Menschen, bei denen
die Ernährungsprobleme tiefer sitzen
und mit Emotionen verbunden sind,
ist es schwieriger.
Karine ist überzeugt,
dass die Misserfolge
auf mangelnden Willen
zurückzuführen sind.
Ich glaube, wer abnehmen
und sein Gewicht halten will,
braucht einen starken Willen.
Man muss sich ständig kontrollieren.
Ich arbeite vielleicht deswegen
für Weight Watchers.
Das hilft mir,
mich unter Kontrolle zu halten.
Schwarze Schokolade - vielleicht 27.
Seit dem Morgen folgt Marjorie
akribisch ihrem Programm.
Sie muss ihr Essen genau berechnen.
Wenn ich nicht zurechtkomme,
schaue ich im Internet
und gebe die Anzahl
der Weight-Watchers-Punkte ein.
Wie viele Punkte für Kakaopulver?
Ungezuckerter Kakao: ein Teelöffel,
null Punkte bis dreimal am Tag.
Also null Punkte. Hop!
Ich habe das gefunden, kleine Beutel
mit einer genauen Dosis.
Ich habe gezählt, wie viele
Esslöffel Haferflocken es sind.
Vier. Also vier Punkte.
Es ist einfach, rasch,
garantiert eine gesunde Ernährung
und macht schnell satt.
Das mit einem Glas Milch
ist ein Frühstück mit sechs Punkten.
Marjorie hat wie alle Kunden
des amerikanischen Unternehmens
eine tägliche Punktezahl,
die nicht überschritten werden darf.
Die Punkte sind genau nach ihrem
Gewicht berechnet worden.
Marjorie hat 29 Punkte pro Tag.
Gut!
* Klingel *
Coucou!
- Salut.
Ihre jüngere Schwester Lorraine
und ihre beste Freundin Lara
verfolgen ihren Kampf.
Ich habe Tee zubereitet.
- (Beide) Cool!
Wie war deine Woche?
Bei Weight Watchers?
Gut! Ich habe 700 g abgenommen.
Ich bin zufrieden.
Es ist cool, aber hart.
Im Winter v.a.
Ja, im Moment ist es schwierig.
Ich habe Mühe, bei Fondue,
Raclette und Schokolade
nicht zu kapitulieren.
Ich muss mich
auf mein Ziel konzentrieren.
20 kg weniger an meinem Geburtstag.
Also noch 4 kg.
Jetzt ist es Februar, und es bleiben
März und April. Das sollte klappen.
Das verspricht Weight Watchers.
500 g pro Woche.
Es ist schwierig. Du findest
die Kleider nicht, die dir gefallen.
Das ist etwas frustrierend.
Deine Kolleginnen
kaufen viele Sachen,
die für dich nicht infrage kommen.
Du kriegst deine Oberarme
gar nicht rein.
Das war auch ein Auslöser dafür,
dass ich dir gesagt habe,
dass ich mit meinem Gewicht
an der oberen Grenze bin
und nicht mehr weiblich sein kann
wie früher.
Das war sehr schwierig für mich.
Es hat mich total genervt.
Sie hat es sich nicht anmerken
lassen, wie unwohl ihr war.
Et puis ...
Sie benutzt den Ausdruck "sich
unwohl fühlen". Das stimmt genau.
Es ist schwierig, vor ihnen
und der Kamera zu sprechen.
Nein, hier schneiden wir.
Ich möchte nur verstehen,
warum es so schwierig ist,
darüber zu sprechen.
Weil, wie ich schon gesagt habe,
ich war immer ...
Das ist schrecklich.
Ich war voller Lebensfreude, ge-
pflegt, trug gerne hübsche Kleider.
Aber wenn du am Abend nach Hause
kommst, dich im Spiegel siehst
und dir nicht mehr gefällst ...
Das ist das Schwierigste.
Überfordert dich das?
Wenn du dich kritisch betrachtest,
kann das brutal sein.
Dein eigenes Urteil
ist vielleicht härter,
als wenn jemand auf der Strasse
sagt, du seist zu dick.
Trotzdem bin ich im Alltag
recht gut damit klargekommen,
bis zu jenem Punkt,
als es klick machte.
Ich konnte einfach nicht mehr,
obwohl man es mir
nicht angesehen hat.
Unangenehme Blicke,
abschätzige Bemerkungen:
Daran hat sich Emilie gewöhnt.
Im Tram bleibt der Platz neben ihr
oft leer.
In ihrer Familie
sind fast alle übergewichtig.
Als sie klein war, musste sie
ihren Teller immer leer essen,
auch wenn sie
nicht mehr hungrig war.
Ihr Mann Gora
ist in Senegal aufgewachsen.
Bevor er in die Schweiz kam, hatte
er nie von Weight Watchers gehört.
In Senegal denken die Leute,
dass sie glücklich ist mit mir,
weil sie Kurven hat.
Man sieht das positiv.
Man findet, einer Frau mit Rundungen
geht es blendend.
Obwohl ich weiss,
dass unsere Kultur hier diktiert,
was als schön gilt und dass sie
wie die andern sein möchte,
unterstütze ich sie auf diesem Weg,
damit sie sich wohl fühlt.
Das Schlankheitsdiktat ist für die
Diätfirmen ein gefundenes Fressen.
Sie verkaufen den Traum
von einer Topmodelfigur
für jede Frau und jeden Mann.
Denis macht nun seit vier Monaten
Diät und hat erst 2 kg abgenommen.
Sie haben 100 g verloren.
Immerhin.
Ich habe mir
nicht besonders Mühe gegeben.
Warum nicht?
- Ich war viel unterwegs.
In Paris z.B.
Da gab es Versuchungen.
Oui.
Da fand ich: Ich habe
ziemlich schnell 2 kg verloren,
aber man hat nichts gesehen.
Man muss wirklich
eine strikte Disziplin verfolgen.
Strikt?
- Ja.
Ich glaube,
wenn ich beim Schokoladeriegel
nicht auf die Punkte achte,
wirkt sich das aus.
Das ist klar.
Denis sträubt sich
gegen die Kontrolle.
Er möchte sich die kleinen Freuden
nicht vermiesen lassen.
Mein Problem ist der Käse.
Es gibt so viele Sorten, und
ich lasse mich schnell verführen.
Was ist das?
- Fridolin.
Der Käse ist absolut genial!
Meine kleine Sünde.
Er schmeckt etwas nussig.
Da kann ich nicht widerstehen.
Ein Stückchen jeden zweiten Abend.
Comme ca.
Wie viel ist das? 50, 60 g?
Das ist für später.
Denis hat seine eigene Methode:
gesunder Menschenverstand.
Er isst etwas weniger
und v.a. bewegt er sich mehr.
Ein bisschen habe ich abgenommen.
Etwas weniger Bauch.
Vorher war ich so ...
Aber ich möchte auch hier abnehmen.
Nicht eben warm!
Abnehmen ist mühsam!
Am Anfang habe ich mir gesagt:
Ja, ich mache ein bisschen mit.
Wenn ich abnehme, okay,
sonst ist es auch egal.
Aber wenn ich nicht abgenommen
hatte, nervte mich das dennoch.
Ich habe mich nicht geschämt,
aber ich fand, dass ich das Ziel
nicht erreicht hatte.
Für Marjorie ist das Gewicht
zur Obsession geworden.
Sie stellt sich am Montag, Dienstag,
Mittwoch und sogar am Donnerstag
vor ihrem Treffen auf die Wage
und hofft,
einige Gramm abgenommen zu haben.
Ich merke sofort, ob sie Gewicht
verloren hat oder nicht.
Je nachdem, wie sie drauf ist.
Sie muss es mir nicht mal sagen.
Diesmal war's nicht gut,
sie hat ein paar Gramm zugenommen.
Seit ein paar Tagen
habe ich einfach keine Lust,
Gemüse und Fisch zu essen.
Ich habe Lust auf Schokolade,
Fleisch und Wein.
Und dann steht er hinter mir
und sagt:
"Pass auf, Marjorie,
wenn du das isst,
wirst du es auf der Waage sehen."
Er verbietet mir zwar nichts,
denn wenn er es tun würde,
würde ich
gleich doppelt so viel essen.
In der ersten Zeit
fühlt man sich gut,
weil man bereit ist,
auf das Gewicht zu achten.
Nach einer Weile führt
die neue strikte Ernährungsweise,
das Punktezählen
und Wiegen der Nahrungsmittel
zu einer zunehmenden Frustration.
Das Leben bringt Hürden
und schwierige Situationen mit sich,
die man meistern muss.
Das macht die Einhaltung der Regeln,
der Einschränkungen
viel schwieriger.
Seit Kurzem hat Marjorie
eine neue Stelle.
Ihr Tagesablauf
ist durcheinandergeraten.
Sie kann sich nicht mehr auf das
ständige Punktezählen konzentrieren
und findet keine Zeit mehr
für die Treffen.
Da waren Geburtstage ...
Ich möchte wieder weitermachen.
Ein bisschen mehr. 600 g.
Das geht.
Es hätte schlimmer sein können.
Karine beschliesst,
Marjorie zu helfen.
Du darfst die Motivation
nicht verlieren.
Darum bin ich hier.
Du musst regelmässiger kommen,
auch wenn es ein anderer Tag ist.
Ich will nicht wechseln,
ich möchte bei dir bleiben.
Nett von dir, aber du musst
dein Idealgewicht erreichen.
Ja, ich bin enttäuscht.
Aber mich bei Weight Watchers
auf die Waage zu stellen,
ist nicht jedes Mal befriedigend.
Am schwierigsten ist es, nicht da
zu sein, wenn du abgenommen hast
und zu kommen, wenn du weisst,
du hast zugenommen.
Aber davon profitierst du,
wenn du kommst und zugenommen hast.
Du wirst mit der Realität
konfrontiert, mit deinem Problem.
Das bewirkt, dass du etwas tust,
damit es besser läuft.
Pausenlos
gegen das Gewicht zu kämpfen ...
Karine weiss, was das heisst.
Wie alle andern Coaches war auch sie
Kundin bei Weight Watchers.
Vor ein paar Jahren
hat sie 26 kg abgenommen.
Doch aus Sorge um ihre Gesundheit
hat sie wieder 18 kg zugelegt.
Sie hat das Programm
von Neuem aufgenommen
und die 18 kg wieder verloren. Seit
einem Jahr hält sie ihr Gewicht.
Ich habe einen Vertrag
mit Weight Watchers,
nach welchem ich
mein Idealgewicht halten muss.
Ich habe 2 kg Toleranz,
so wie unsere Kunden auch.
Drei- bis viermal im Jahr
müssen wir uns bei der Firmenleitung
auf die Wage stellen.
Wenn unser Gewicht stimmt, sehr gut.
Wenn nicht, legt man uns nahe,
wieder zu unseren guten Gewohnheiten
zurückzukehren.
Heute ist ein wichtiger Tag.
Karine muss auf die Waage.
Trotz ihrer täglichen Bemühungen
geht sie besorgt
zum Treffen der Coaches in Freiburg.
C'est le meme,
mais ils nous ont fait descendre.
Alors on n'a pas de train,
on va etre en retard.
Ich bin am Limit.
Voila. Mais bon ...
Vielleicht meint es
die Freiburger Waage gut.
Si elle est sympa, ca va.
Das ist immer
ein etwas schwieriger Moment,
die Konfrontation
mit unserem Gewicht.
Es ist das einzige, was heute
ein bisschen stressig sein kann.
Die Coaches kommen aus der ganzen
Westschweiz und dem Tessin.
Wie für ihre Kunden
beginnt das Ganze mit der Waage.
Carmen, die Regionalleiterin,
wiegt sie.
Super, Christelle!
Hallo, Giuliana, gute Reise gehabt?
- Oui, merci.
Guten Tag, Karine.
- Bonjour, Carmen.
Ca va?
- Oui.
Es geht gut, die Waage ist nett.
Ja, super.
Sie sind unsere Vertreterinnen.
Wenn ihr Gewicht stimmt, ist das
ein gutes Image für Weight Watchers.
Hat sie ihr Gewicht?
- Perfekt.
Ich bin zufrieden, alles ist gut.
Die Frauen hier sind stolz,
wenn sie "auf ihrem Gewicht" sind,
wie sie sagen. Und stolz darauf,
als Coach auserwählt zu sein.
Aber auf die kleinste Entgleisung
wird mit dem Finger gezeigt.
Carla, kennst du dein Idealgewicht?
- Ja.
Das wäre?
- 66.
Was ist seit dem letzten Mal
geschehen?
Da warst du noch im grünen Bereich.
Ich habe eine Woche Ferien
im Ausland gemacht. Eine Hochzeit.
Ein schöner Tag. Doch alles
zu managen ist nicht leicht.
Dein Ziel ist aber auch
dein Idealgewicht.
Ja.
Was würdest du deinen Kunden sagen?
- Für die nächste Woche?
Ich werde mich ans Programm halten,
meine tägliche Anzahl Punkte
respektieren und auch darauf achten,
dass ich
meine körperliche Aktivität erfülle.
Sie könnte bis 68 zunehmen,
aber jetzt hat sie 2 kg mehr.
Sie ist 4 kg
über ihrem Idealgewicht.
Man hat einen Spielraum von 2 kg.
Ich habe also 2 kg mehr.
Das ist immer sehr heikel. Man sagt
sich: "Das ist ja nicht sehr viel."
Aber wenn man das durchlässt
und nichts sagt,
sind es in drei Wochen
vielleicht 5 kg.
Wenn es dir hilft, kannst du mir
dein Gewicht jede Woche mitteilen.
Es wird gehen.
Bisher hat es auch geklappt.
Auch wenn sie mitfühlend wirkt,
muss Carmen ihre Coaches
an die Einhaltung der Regeln
erinnern.
Carla
kommt mit einer Ermahnung davon,
doch die Konsequenzen
können gravierender sein.
In den USA,
der Wiege der Weight Watchers,
zeigt sich,
wie weit die Marke gehen kann.
In Houston, Texas haben wir
zwei ehemalige Coaches getroffen.
94.5 Buzz. I'm Josh.
Buzz Fest 34 on the way.
Heute ist Josh Benoit Radiomoderator.
Vorher hatte er vier Jahre lang
für Weight Watchers gearbeitet,
bis er kündigte, enttäuscht und
wütend. Er erzählt, was er erlebte.
Nach einem Treffen kamen
ein paar neue Mitglieder herein,
und ich zeigte ihnen dieses Bild
und sagte:
"So habe ich angefangen."
"Wow", fanden sie, "unglaublich"!
Und so sah ich aus,
als ich die Meetings führte.
Ich nahm von 160 auf 90 kg ab.
Dieses Gewicht konnte ich
ein Jahr lang halten.
Dann aber holte mich das Leben ein.
Ich hatte nicht mehr so viel Zeit
und nahm wieder zu.
Da begannen die Probleme. Sie
setzten mich wirklich unter Druck.
Die Gewichtskontrolle der Coaches
in den USA ist noch rigoroser
als in der Schweiz.
Josh versuchte,
dem Programm zu folgen,
doch er nahm Kilo um Kilo wieder zu.
Wir mussten jeden Monat
auf die Waage.
Und unser Gewicht
musste konstant bleiben.
Wie war das?
- Fürchterlich.
Wer will schon immer gewogen werden?
Es war hart für mich. Sie sagten:
"Du nimmst wieder zu, also
nehmen wir dir dein Treffen weg."
Sie beschlossen,
mir das Treffen wegzunehmen,
das ich für unsere Kirche
organisiert hatte.
Ich hatte alles
selbst in die Wege geleitet.
Sie haben das getan,
um mich zu bestrafen.
Oft manipulierten sie
ihre Angestellten
in ein Schuldgefühl hinein.
Und wie steht es
mit den Anstellungsbedingungen?
Da gibt es die höheren Kader
in New York. Sehr gut bezahlt.
Doch die kleinen Angestellten
verdienen nicht viel.
Man erwartete von uns, dass wir
viele unbezahlte Überstunden machen.
Von den Leuten,
die an die Treffen gehen,
werden 10-15 %
Weight-Watchers-Angestellte.
Doch diese Leute werden ausgenützt,
schlecht behandelt
und nicht anständig bezahlt.
Sie gehen und kehren nie mehr
zu Weight Watchers zurück.
Sie fühlen sich betrogen.
Genau aus diesem Grund haben mehrere
Tausend amerikanische Angestellte
zwei Klagen
gegen ihr Unternehmen eingereicht.
Wir haben uns
ihre Sammelklagen angesehen.
Die Coaches beschuldigen
Weight Watchers,
sich nicht an das Mindesteinkommen
zu halten,
die Überstunden nicht zu vergüten
und die Abgangsvergütungen
nicht zu überweisen.
Um einen Prozess zu vermeiden,
der dem Image enorm schaden würde,
hat Weight Watchers eine Zahlung
akzeptiert, knapp 8 Mio. $.
Ein verkraftbarer Betrag
für ein Unternehmen,
welches jährlich
1,5 Mrd. Umsatz erzielt.
Seither gilt das Gesetz
der Verschwiegenheit.
Keiner der Angestellten
hat das Recht,
etwas über seine Arbeitsbedingungen
auszusagen,
weder in den USA noch in Europa.
Wieder in der Schweiz.
Auch Karine möchte nicht
über ihr Salär reden.
Doch nach unseren Informationen
sind die Bedingungen ähnlich
wie in den USA.
40 Fr. pro Treffen, Vorbereitungen
und Administratives inbegriffen.
Eine Zahl, die Weight Watchers
nicht bestätigen wollte.
Karine hat eine gute Ausbildung
im Marketing
und könnte eine viel besser bezahlte
Stelle bekommen.
Doch sie hat Angst, ohne Programm
ihre 26 kg wieder zuzunehmen.
Oui, c'est parti!
- Alors, les cuisses comme ca.
Il faut tirer la.
Marjorie ist nach wie vor überzeugt,
dass sie ihr Ziel erreichen wird,
d.h.: weitere 15 kg abnehmen,
dank des weltweit führenden
Schlankheitsunternehmens.
Doch ihr Gewicht stagniert.
Sie versucht es mit einem Kraftakt,
dem Basistraining für die Teilnahme
an einem Lauf, obwohl sie sich
mit ihrem Übergewicht schaden könnte.
Lauf mehr auf den Zehenspitzen!
Ich schaff das nicht!
J'ai un putain de poids.
Atme tief!
Das tut so weh!
- Wir haben bald die Hälfte.
Mehr, oder?
- Ja, mehr.
Ich kann nicht mehr.
Oui?
Ich muss aufhören.
Nein!
Non, viens!
Ich bin am Ende.
Ich möchte es wirklich schaffen,
ohne Unterbruch zu laufen.
Aber ich habe keine Kondition.
Und jetzt tut es mir hier weh.
Es braucht noch mind. 15 solcher
Trainingsläufe, bis sie es schafft,
von dort bis zum Auto
mit normaler Durchschnitts-
geschwindigkeit zu laufen.
Gehen?
- Nein, nein.
Beim Gehen schaffe ich es
ohne anhalten, beim Rennen nicht.
Du checkst das gar nicht! Ich gebe
dir Wasserflaschen, du läufst damit.
Dann sehen wir,
ob du noch so schnell rennst.
Du trägst nur 50 kg mit dir rum,
das ist nicht so wie bei mir.
Marjorie hat genug.
Sie hat das Gefühl,
dass die ganze Mühe nichts bringt.
Pour Marjorie, oui.
- Qu'est-ce que il dit?
Emilie kann ihr neues Gewicht
gut halten. 7 kg weniger.
Doch ihre Kleider
sind ihr jetzt alle zu gross.
Ich muss mir neue Sachen kaufen,
auf jeden Fall eine Grösse weniger.
Ich habe den Gürtel nicht angezogen,
das tue ich sonst,
v.a., wenn ich ausgehe. Sonst muss
ich die Hose immer raufziehen.
Emilie folgt dem Programm akribisch.
Sie hat beschlossen, ein für alle mal
ihre Ernährung im Griff zu behalten.
Um das jeden Tag zu schaffen,
notiert sie genau, was sie isst.
Auch das kleinste Häppchen
zwischendurch.
Eigentlich esse ich nicht viel.
Mein Problem ist das Knabbern.
Ich merke: da ein bisschen,
dort ein bisschen.
Ich frage mich, warum ich jede halbe
Stunde oder Stunde etwas essen muss.
Zu realisieren, dass ich erst
vor einer Stunde gegessen habe ...
Das bedeutet,
dass ich gar nicht hungrig bin.
Ich habe am Mittag richtig gegessen.
Auch Denis ist ziemlich zufrieden
mit seiner Diät.
In sieben Monaten
hat er 7 kg abgenommen.
Ich fühle mich besser -
vitaler, dynamischer.
Ich habe mich daran gewöhnt,
dass ich aufpassen muss.
Aber wenn mir in einem Restaurant
das Essen wirklich gut schmeckt,
geniesse ich es und versuche,
nicht zu übertreiben.
Kein zweites Mal schöpfen
und vernünftige Portionen.
Ich kann nicht sagen,
dass ich mich kasteie.
Obwohl seine Diät ziemlich gut läuft,
zählt Denis seine Punkte nicht.
Er notiert sich
seine Mahlzeiten ungefähr,
die Punkte aber
vergisst er systematisch.
Da haben wir Cornflakes. Thunfisch
mit Teigwaren und Grapefruit.
Da habe ich nicht viel gegessen.
Wenn ich es notiere, merke ich,
wenn ich an einem Tag mehr esse
als sonst. Das ist ein Anhaltspunkt.
Vielleicht sollte ich mich
strikter an das Programm halten,
damit ich genau weiss, wie viele
Punkte ich verbraucht habe.
Aber das ist die nächste Etappe.
Der grosse Tag ist gekommen.
Obwohl sie fast nicht trainiert hat,
will Marjorie am Colour-Lauf
in Lyon teilnehmen.
Zusammen mit ihren Freundinnen
läuft sie in einer Gruppe.
Doch 5 km laufen
ist härter, als sie gedacht hat.
Ich habe die 5 km geschafft.
So anstrengend!
Ich bin zwar nicht immer gerannt,
aber ich bin angekommen.
Das war mein Ziel.
Marjorie hat ihre sportliche
Herausforderung gemeistert.
Doch abgenommen hat sie nicht.
Die letzte Zeit war schwierig,
zumal ich auch Geburtstag hatte.
Zwei intensive Wochen,
mit Feiern am Mittwoch, Donnerstag,
Freitag, Samstag.
Also ich glaube,
ich bin jetzt nicht auf der Linie,
aber das kann man ja auch nicht
immer. Ich sehe es eher positiv.
Ich habe gefeiert und jetzt muss ich
mich eben wieder zusammenreissen.
Wir reisen in den Osten Frankreichs,
nach Saint Die.
Dreimal hat sie das Programm
von Weight Watchers mitgemacht.
Das Resultat: Sie hat nicht
abgenommen, sondern zugenommen.
Das erste Mal habe ich das Programm
18 Monate lang gemacht
und 18 kg verloren.
Das war eher verblüffend.
Sogar meine Betreuerin
konnte es kaum fassen.
Ich hielt mich sehr genau
an das Programm, Punkt um Punkt!
Ich zählte wirklich alle Punkte
und achtete strikt darauf,
was auf meinen Teller kam.
Ich hörte mit Knabbereien auf
und machte 2-3 Std. Aquagymnastik
pro Woche.
Für meinen völlig untrainierten
Körper eine echte Herausforderung!
Das hat 18 Wochen funktioniert.
18 kg in 18 Wochen
ist ein brutaler Gewichtsverlust.
Doch ihr Coach bremst sie nicht.
Im Gegenteil! Sie gratuliert Alexia.
Dann wird Alexia schwanger.
Es gelingt ihr, das Gewicht während
der Schwangerschaft zu halten,
doch nach der Geburt
lässt sie sich gehen.
Sie verliert die Kontrolle.
Ich nahm die ganzen 18 kg,
die ich abgenommen hatte, wieder zu.
Und noch 7-8 kg dazu.
Das war mehr als damals, als ich
bei Weight Watchers begonnen hatte.
Alexia will
auf den rechten Weg zurück.
Sie startet einen zweiten Versuch.
Immerhin habe ich
etwas Gewicht verloren, etwa 10 kg.
Aber das war hart. Ich habe viel
länger gebraucht für diese 10 kg.
An einem gewissen Punkt
habe ich mich gehen lassen.
Es waren die Festtage,
das Weihnachtsessen,
Süssigkeiten, Schokolade, Terrine,
all das.
Und nachdem ich alles zwei Wochen
lang fahren gelassen hatte,
gab ich auf.
Und Sie haben wieder zugenommen?
Ja, ich habe diese 10 kg
wieder zugenommen,
und wahrscheinlich 7-8 kg mehr.
Von dem Tag an gerechnet, als ich
das erste Weight-Watches-Programm
angefangen hatte bis zum Schluss
waren es sicher ... gute 15 kg mehr.
Ich habe also definitiv zugenommen.
Es ist schlicht gesagt eine Spirale.
Wenn man merkt,
dass man sich gehen lässt,
fühlt man sich irgendwie schuldig.
Und bei mir führt das dazu,
dass ich esse.
Also je schlechter ich mich fühle,
desto mehr esse ich,
und je mehr ich esse,
desto schlechter fühle ich mich.
Ein Teufelskreis.
Man fragt sich:
Wann komme ich endlich
aus dieser Spirale der Schuldgefühle
und des Essens heraus?
Kosten von über 2'000 Fr.,
15 kg schwerer als zuvor
und ein zunehmendes Unbehagen.
Für Alexia ist die Bilanz nach dem
Weight-Watchers-Programm dramatisch.
Wir möchten wissen, wie die Direktion
des Unternehmens solche Fälle sieht.
Wir begeben uns zum europäischen Sitz
der Firma in Düsseldorf.
Die Marketing-Chefin empfängt uns.
Sie lehnt es ab, die Verantwortung
für das Scheitern einzelner Kunden
zu übernehmen.
Man muss auch immer
den Faktor Mensch mit einbeziehen.
Es ist ja keine Pille, die ich nehme
und die mich schlank hält.
Es ist eine Verhaltensänderung,
und da muss man sich
den Einzelnen ansehen:
Hat er das beibehalten
oder haben sich alte Routinen wieder
eingeschlichen?
Für Nicolette Hehn sind Kunden
wie Alexia die grosse Ausnahme.
Wir sind eigentlich, was wir von den
Kunden auch als Feedback bekommen,
immer sehr zufrieden.
Wir machen normalerweise einmal
im Jahr eine Zufriedenheitsstudie.
Da fragen wir, wie zufrieden
die Leute mit uns sind.
Das freut mich schon, dass
die Mehrzahl, also über 90 %,
sagt, sie seien zumindest mit ihrem
Gewichtsverlust zufrieden.
Das finde ich
ein schönes Kompliment.
Wie repräsentativ sind
solche internen Kundenfeedbacks?
Übergewicht ist zum Problem
für die Volksgesundheit geworden.
Forscher interessieren sich
für die längerfristigen Auswirkungen
von Diäten.
Ihre Erkenntnisse sind alarmierend.
2007 hat die Universität
von Kalifornien,
die zu den fortschrittlichsten
in Sachen Fettleibigkeit zählt,
eine langfristige Studie
veröffentlicht.
Diese hinterfragt
das Grundprinzip der Diäten.
Nach einem Jahr sind die Gewichts-
verluste spektakulär, bis 30 kg.
Aber nach vier oder fünf Jahren
haben die Leute
wieder ihr ursprüngliches Gewicht,
einige wiegen sogar noch mehr.
Wie sieht die langfristige Bilanz bei
den Kunden von Weight Watchers aus?
Drei Jahre nach der Diät?
Das herauszufinden ist schwierig,
denn das Unternehmen hat an keiner
unabhängigen Studie teilgenommen.
Interessiert es Sie nicht, was mit
den Leuten z.B. nach drei Jahren ist?
Für solche ganz konkreten Zahlen
machen wir die klinischen Studien.
Sie sollen uns auch objektiv helfen,
dass man sagen kann,
dass, wenn man das durchzieht,
seine Ernährung umstellt
und mehr Bewegung integriert,
das auch langfristig halten kann.
Das können wir in den klinischen
Studien immer ganz schön belegen.
Ich kann halt einen Kunden ...
Ich sehe ihn ja vielleicht
nach drei Jahren nicht mehr.
Ich weiss nicht,
wie sein Leben weiterlief.
Weight Watchers kennt diese
Resultate nach drei Jahren sicher.
Ich glaube,
sie sind auf dem Laufenden.
Sie selbst müssen
interne Studien gemacht haben,
die sie aber nicht veröffentlichen -
Studien,
die dieselben Resultate zeigen.
Sie stellen eine Gewichtsabnahme
nach einem Jahr fest,
und das wird natürlich publiziert,
das ist auch schmeichelhaft für sie.
Die Studien über drei Jahre hingegen
werden sicher nicht veröffentlicht,
denn sie wären
ein schlechtes Verkaufsargument.
Dennoch sind diese
medizinisch einwandfrei belegt.
Es ist erstaunlich,
dass man bei 50 Jahren Geschichte
nicht einmal fünf Jahre
als Referenzwert genommen
und die Kunden verpflichtet hat,
nach drei und fünf Jahren
nochmals Bescheid zu geben.
Warum hat man das nie gemacht?
Da frage ich in den USA mal nach.
Das finde ich eigentlich
eine gute Idee.
Trotz unserer Nachfragen
liefert uns die Direktion
keinen wissenschaftlichen Beweis
ihrer Resultate.
Seit Jahren
ermutige ich Patienten dazu,
diese Art von Unternehmen
einzuklagen
wegen unlauterer Werbung
oder Irreführung.
Denn solange keine Klagen vorliegen,
gibt es auch kein Verbot.
Warum reichen die übergewichtigen
Menschen keine Klage ein?
Weil sie überzeugt sind,
dass der Fehler bei ihnen liegt.
Sie fühlen sich schuldig.
Aber wenn eine Firma ein Produkt
verkauft, das nicht wirkt,
muss sie
auch die Verantwortung übernehmen.
Aber was tun,
wenn eine Diät nichts nützt?
Sind die Betroffenen
zum Übergewicht verdammt?
Und v.a. dazu,
sich in ihrer Haut unwohl zu fühlen?
Nein, sagt die Psychologin. Aber
oft muss jemand an sich arbeiten.
Und das versucht sie mit Mylene,
einer ihrer Patientinnen.
Man ist zu Hause,
langweilt sich ein bisschen,
aber man ist nicht unbedingt
niedergeschlagen. Kennen Sie das?
Ja.
Kommt Ihnen das Essen
manchmal als zwanghaft vor?
Ja.
Können Sie uns erklären, warum?
Weil ich dann hinauskann,
um einzukaufen,
auch wenn ich
meinen Parkplatz verliere.
Wenn Sie weggehen,
fühlen Sie sich erleichtert?
Ja.
Also legt sich der Zwang, wenn Sie
realisieren, dass Sie essen werden?
Unbewusst kompensiere ich
die schlechte Laune mit Essen.
Wenn Sie sich mit dem Gewicht
befassen, wie gehen Sie vor?
Ich nehme rasch ab,
wenn ich gut drauf bin.
Dann habe ich keine Lust mehr,
mich vollzustopfen.
Sie brauchen dann
nicht einmal eine Diät?
Sie brauchen also keinen Druck
von aussen, um abzunehmen?
Es geht nur darum,
ihr Gefühlsleben ins Lot zu bringen.
Dann können Sie
wieder Gewicht verlieren,
auch ohne eigentliche Absicht.
Wenn es ein Stressproblem
im Leben gibt,
sollte man sich vielleicht
die Zeit nehmen und überlegen:
"Soll ich den Job wechseln?
Oder den Partner?"
"Meine Aktivitäten reduzieren?
Mein Leben anders organisieren?"
"Soll ich umziehen?"
Manchmal liegen die Ursachen
von Stress und Essstörungen
in grundlegenden Dingen, die man
infrage stellen und verändern muss,
damit es besser für uns passt.
Schlank sein ist möglich.
Sich wohlfühlen ist wichtig,
vielleicht aber auch
mit ein paar Rundungen am Körper.
Emilie hat ihr Etappenziel erreicht:
10 kg weniger.
Aber ihr Gewicht
stagniert seit mehreren Wochen.
Sie schränkt sich weiterhin ein,
um noch mehr abzunehmen.
Dieses kleine Bisschen
macht 10 g aus.
Und wie viele Punkte?
- Einen.
Die Gefühle im Griff haben
ist das Schwierigste.
Wenn man genervt ist,
sollte man einen andern Weg
als das Essen finden,
um sich zu beruhigen.
Ich sage mir dann:
"Nein, jetzt wird nicht gegessen!"
Ich trinke ein Glas Wasser
oder gehe hinaus.
Mache etwas anderes,
um durchzuatmen.
Aber es gelingt mir nicht immer.
Doch meine Ausrutscher
sind seltener geworden,
weil ich mich doch
meistens beherrschen kann.
Denis hat 10 kg abgenommen.
Aber er hat sich
ein besseres Resultat erhofft.
Ich bin eigentlich etwas enttäuscht,
denn ich habe weniger schnell
abgenommen als erwartet.
Das hat mich ein bisschen geärgert.
Ich habe versucht,
mich zu kontrollieren,
habe den Käse stark reduziert, auch
Süsses, und habe mich mehr bewegt.
Bin mehr zu Fuss gegangen,
zum Schwimmen,
aber die Resultate waren bescheiden.
Das hat mich etwas genervt.
Marjorie hat in den letzten Wochen
2 kg zugenommen.
Sie sucht Fotos, auf denen sie
noch mehr Übergewicht hat.
Dazu hat ihr Coach Karine
geraten, um sie zu motivieren.
Aber Marjorie hat enorm Mühe,
sich erneut einzuschränken.
Ich bin es leid.
Es bringt sowieso nichts.
Nach zwei Jahren
die Scheiben Schinken aufschreiben,
drei Löffel Reis, drei Punkte ...
Wenn du mich fragst: "Hast du lieber
einen Apfel oder Schokoladenkuchen",
sage ich: "Schokoladenkuchen!"
Das wird sich nie ändern.
Sicher wäre ein Apfel besser,
aber er macht keinen Spass
und schmeckt weniger gut.
Ich bin so aufgewachsen.
Beim Essen waren wir als Familie
alle zusammen am Tisch.
Das bedeutet mir Geborgenheit,
Liebe. Das zählt auch.
Vielleicht sollte ich
zu Karine gehen
und das Programm
noch einmal von Grund auf mitmachen.
Dass sie mir
noch einmal alles erklärt,
auch wenn ich es schon längst weiss.
Ich sage nicht,
dass ich Coach sein könnte,
aber ich kenne alle Tipps,
weiss, welche Nahrungsmittel
anderen entsprechen.
Doch alles noch einmal von vorn zu
machen, könnte vielleicht bewirken,
dass ich wieder abnehme.
Guten Tag,
willkommen zu diesem Treffen.
Wir befassen uns heute
mit der körperlichen Betätigung.
Marjorie, sind Sie zufrieden
mit dem Resultat der Waage?
Ich habe 200 g verloren.
Das ist negativ.
Aber ich bin trotzdem zufrieden,
auch wenn es Gramm um Gramm ist.
Das ist positiv.
Also alles gut?
Nein, es könnte besser sein.
Aber das dauert.
Mit 200 g pro Mal
bin ich noch einige Zeit hier.
Voila.
Am Ende der Dreharbeiten ist Denis
der Einzige, der weiterhin abnimmt.
Emilie hat schon wieder 3 kg
zugenommen.
Combien de kilos, rappelez-vous,
vous avez perdu?
Et le sachant aussi ...
Und von Marjorie
haben wir nichts mehr gehört.
Sie kommt nicht mehr zu den Treffen.